تبنت كتائب القسام الجناح العسكري لحركه
حماس عمليه حوار التي قتل فيها اثنان من
المستوطنين الشهر الماضي ونعت القسام في
بيان الشهيد عبد الفتاح خروشه منفذ
العمليه كما اكدت ان عمليه حوار جاءت ردا
ودفاعا عن الشعب الفلسطيني في وجه جرائم
الاحتلال ودعت كتائب القسام الى تصعيد
المقاومه المسلحه في وجه الاحتلال
والاشتباك معهم في كل فلسطين المحتله
دفاعا عن الوطن والمقدسات
معنى الان من غزه مراسل الجزيره وائل
الدحدوح نرحب بك وائل ونتعرف من خلالك على
المزيد من التفاصيل حول بيان القسام الذي
تبنت فيه عمليه حوار
البيان يعني صدر يوم امس او ليله امس عقب
الاجتياح لمنطقه جنين
ووقوع هذا العدد من الشهداء بعد اشتباك
استمر لساعات في هذه المنطقه
وبالتالي البيان ربما تبنى اثنين من
المقاومين الذين سقطوا خلال عمليه
الاشتباك مع قوات الاحتلال الاسرائيلي
وزفهم الى الشعب الفلسطيني كما زف بقيه
الشهداء الذين سقطوا خلال الاشتباك وقال
بان احدهم هو من نفذ عمليه حواره التي قتل
فيها مستوطنان اسرائيليان قبل نحو 10 ايام
تقريبا
ولكن البيان لم يتبنى هذه العمليه بشكل
رسمي
وبالتالي يمكن الاعتبار ان هذا البيان
ربما يتبنى بشكل غير لكن بشكل رسمي لا
يمكن اعتبار ان القسام تبنت هذه العمليه
بشكل رسمي وان كان هذا
الشهيد الذي نعدته واعتبرته
بالاشط والمجاهد او القيادي فيها هو احد
اعضائها وبالتالي ربما يكون هناك احتمال
يبقى احتمال بانه قد تصرف بدون تعليمات
مباشره من قياده كتائب القسام ولذلك
البيان لم ياتي على تبني واضح وصريح لهذه
العمليه كما عهدنا في العمليات الواضحه
والمباشره والبيانات التي تصدر عن كتائب
القسام لكن يمكن اعتبار انه تبني غير
مباشر من قبل كتائب القسام وفق ما يرى
المراقبون
ويستنتج الشارع الفلسطيني من خلال هذا
البيان بالتاكيد هذا الوضع ربما ياتي في
سياق هذا الت المراه الكبيره والتوتر
الكبير الذي يسود عموم الضفه الغربيه
لاسيما في الاونه الاخيره في منطقتي جنين
ونابلس من خلال الاجتياحات المتكرره لقوات
الاحتلال الاسرائيلي والتي عاده ما ينجم
عنها سقوط اعداد كبيره من الشهداء وفي هذا
الموضوع او ايذاء هذا الموضوع بالتاكيد
الفصائل الفلسطينيه اصدرت عديد من
البيانات من ضمنها بيان كتائب القسام
وبيان حركه حماسه التي اعتبرت بان استمرار
الاحتلال في هذه السياسه سياسه الاجتياحات
وقتل واغتيال المواطنين والمقاومين
الفلسطينيين في مناطق الضفه الغربيه لن
تقف مكتوفه الايدي سواء حركه حماس او
الفصائل الفلسطينيه فصائل المقاومه
الفلسطينيه التي كان فحوى بياناتها يدور
حول هذا الموضوع واعاده التاكيد على
النقاط والمعادلات التي ارسلتها ثبتتها
خلال الاشهر والسنوات الماضيه بانه لن
يسمح بالاستفراد بمناطق الضفه الغربيه من
قبل قوات الاحتلال الاسرائيلي وتقف غزه
مكتوفه الايدي ولذلك كنا نشاهد في كل مره
من الاجتياحات اطلاق بعض الصواريخ وان كان
في منطقه غلاف غزه تاكيدا على ان غزه لا
تريد بالتاكيد الذهاب الى حرب لكنها لن
تقف مكتوفه الايدي اذاها سياسه الاستفراد
الاسرائيلي بالقدس وبمناطق الضفه الغربيه
شكرا لك من غزه مراسله الجزيره وائل
الدحدوح